but a lot of the coins have been lost
and we're not gonna get to uh last loss
yeah because some people put them in
non-custodial wallets which means that
there's no it's not on an exchange
there's no middleman it's just there on
the blockchain and in order to access
that you need the private keys and the
seed phrase and that takes a lot of
personal responsibility to remember
there's nobody at HR that you can call
there's no Karen you can call and be
like Karen Like There's No 1 800 Bitcoin
nothing like that no Yellow Pages no
Karen
um so that's the good thing you know if
you copy the address wrong if you forget
when you're copying the address and Skip
one letter like it's bad business all
right so let's break that down there's
people out there who could potentially
have millions in the bank well there's
always but they forgot the [ __ ]
password there's also all those is that
a terrible boating accidents yeah I've
had so many boating accidents drop it in
the ocean you know real sad
you know I think Alex Jones had like
some a bunch of Bitcoin on a laptop and
he lost it he lost the laptop so isn't
this a red flag for Bitcoin though no no
no tell me why I'm thinking well I have
five million dollars in Bitcoin boom
it's overboard now tell me why I'm not
that's the trade-off for not being
confiscatable like you have to
confiscatable and nobody's given I got a
couple million in the bank nobody's
coming after my money
oh that's because you're not gonna have
any unpopular opinions but I however
have a lot of unpopular opinions okay I
can say so because you have an unpopular
opinion they're gonna come after your
money well that's possible like we
established that Justin Trudeau has no
problem doing that to Canadians well
with the Go for free money of the okay
so this is a fear of yours so if you
have this sorry it's a reality yeah I
mean if you're saying uncomfortable
truths think about how many times in
history people have had their wealth
confiscated like I can confiscated all
kinds of things I can give you a really
recent example don't forget Trudeau but
like in Cyprus it's called the cypriot
haircut of 2013. set people in Cyprus
you've had over a hundred thousand Euros
in their bank account woke up one day
with that money gone because the economy
was in Dire Straits the EU commission
has just had the authority to confiscate
the money in order to pay back whatever
needed to be paid back that is
disgusting it just happened in Lebanon
right before that yeah well right before
that so it sounds like the more shaky
your country the more you really need to
be looking at Bitcoin oh no we have this
attitude like it can't happen here I
don't know why anybody believes that
anymore we never thought 40 of the money
supply would uh get uh printed in the
last like three years right nobody would
think that oh you never thought Canada
Canada the polite country Justin Trudeau
the man of the people the kind
good-hearted man the feminist damn
Trudeau he confiscated people's money
because they didn't want to take a
substance they didn't want to put a
substance inside their body they didn't
want to take a substance that was just
told that was pushed down their throat
something which hasn't really been
tested long enough we don't need to get
into this yeah and now and now they're
charging people legally in Canada
Canadians who sent Bitcoin to other
Canadians that were in the that trucker
situation and bro
part of the the just to be Crystal Clear
part of the Allure or the benefit of
Bitcoin is being is is I'm a little
paranoid but it's not even paranoia it's
like I'm paranoid of the reality of what
could happen
[Music]